thinking about you recently because we
did a week of shows in san francisco
just the other week and i was yes i
think of you often san francisco la
bamba and i think of you constantly and
uh
and uh
and but you know and i uh i did a
segment with your old friend bob
and uh and it's funny
but it's funny because i realized at the
time that you guys were both on the show
full house together now both of you come
full circle and you're both working on
nbc
he's working on the game show the game
show one out of 100 or something
i thought i took one versus a hundred so
those are your odds of getting another
job after doing a game show
the guy bunched my nuts all the time i
mean
he comes on here and just talks about me
the whole time he is obsessed with you
he's a little weird and and then he
calls me says
he calls me so did you see me on conan i
talked about and then he makes me go to
his house and watch him talking about me
on your show it's
i swear to god well what is he like
rubbing his chest while it's all
happening yes seems very straight i want
you to come over and watch me talk about
you with me
yeah i didn't do it like that you did it
like that mine was a more general yours
was very specific
so you got to get the nipples you got to
oh really
um i want to ask you about this picture
it was just uh showed up in all the
magazines this is a picture of you and
zach braff on the red carpet and you
pressed hog yeah you got best hug from
uh from some magazine uh your looks you
looks like you're going in for the kill
on this one
what's going on here what happened you
know that's zach raff right yeah i i was
at the gold
i hugged so many guys i don't remember
which one that was at the golden globes
and i and i just read some article that
he was depressed or so he said he was
having so i went up and gave a hug i
said don't be depressed you know we you
know we have a good life and then i saw
that picture and i got depressed
no he's a good guy yeah yeah he's a good
man i i have to congratulate you er
so uh was was having its troubles kind
of on the ropes and then you enter the
cast and you've re-energized the whole
show and it's uh it's a big hit you must
be excited people this is this is great
well you know it's an institution i mean
the show is honestly the show was on
uprise before i came on the show i
started doing well last year and this
season we've done great it's it's just
been a blessing you know i think that
that show was living off stamos fever
right now no that's what i think
it shows you well uh one of the things
that you've you've added a lot of sex
appeal oh really thank you yeah and not
me personally saying that but uh
women people saying that but um
do you feel like they're constantly
trying to get situations where you
[Music]
there's writing situations where you've
got to operate on this patient okay but
let me take my shirt off first is that
happening a lot i'm not a shirt-off guy
i'm not the celex a shirt-off guy i used
to be you were good
you were one of the kings
but i i don't know how to because i'm a
scrawny little guy so i'm like pumped
like i read guys you know like brad pitt
and stallone they pump up in between did
you ever do that pumping
no no it showed but um
yeah no you do the thing so i'm like
hiding in the i didn't know the cast
very well so i'm hiding in this back
room like doing push-ups you know and i
banged my head on a pipe or a toilet or
something and i'm you know i'm pumped
and i haven't you're self-conscious why
are you self-conscious about taking your
shirt off do you i'm just not a shirt
off what are you getting at coney
i have i actually this is not
but i actually i have a very uh i have a
this is not why up cause i take but i
have a very strange belly but i have a
weird belly button
when i was a kid i had hernia and they
they thought i had they told my parents
you have a hernia and they went in to
cut it open and they said he's got no
hernia and they sewed it up and it was
stevie wonder was the doctor so they had
this scar
you know my belly button looks like a
small like a no like a small nose like
it's it's not it's
your belly button looks like a nose yes
it looks like a small nose it's just a
horrible belly button i i you know what
am i gonna say you gotta see it now i
think
[Applause]
you guys got a show i'm not uh
[Applause]
adjust the contrast on your set
because this is like nine layers of
makeup what you're about to see is
actual conan o'brien's skin tone
[Applause]
you're
uh max could we have a drum
this
roll
please
it's terrible
[Music]
it's
it's not uh
it's like
it's uh
it's not good yeah i had a i had an ex
who wanted to pierce it
which would have been weird you could
put a magnum mustache
[Applause]
okay then
now put it on
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what kind of television show is this
[Applause]
i love i love trying to segue into a
plug now
well very good uh the er
the er season finale airs this thursday
night at 10 on nbc it's a great show
watching john's seamless everybody